when is the last time you saw this you
know the first every once in a while
well I could be jet-lagged somewhere all
over the world and this movies playing
it'll be on TV and in the middle of the
night and I'll watch a scene or two but
I haven't watched the whole movie since
we made it so and I think there's stuff
in here that isn't usually seen I have
stuff in the beginning in the
Philippines is and with the [ __ ] in
the you know in the beginning with my
father that a lot of that stuff I don't
think he's ever shown it certainly is
not going to be on television right you
know so this has been a very emotional
experience for people it was a it's also
the first time you've watched it with
your wife who is here as well Carrie
you're very happy to to share that with
stand-up Carrie hi Carrie wife Carol II
know you know it's funny I I'm at an age
now I'm at the dinosaur age where I get
these awards for for the career and I
and they put together these clips of my
my career but it's more it's my life you
know from when I was a kid to to now so
these are really deep experiences for me
to see these other times in my life but
also to remember the I remember
everything about making this movie
everything and everything you can't see
you know there wasn't in the movie I
remember and what we went through to
make the movie in the initial meetings
we had to make the movie and the time of
my life it was when we did this and I
mean it was all I'm getting flooded with
the whole thing it's very emotional for
me I spoke to Lou actually before I came
and he's really sorry he couldn't be
here and I'd run into Lou every once in
a while and we always embrace and have
good memories of this shoot he's really
sorry can be Lou
I have to tell one story that with
Lulu's brilliant in this I also forgot
how brilliant he is in his film if I was
I was at that stage of my life that that
I really this I'm just working so hard
on this it was all I was doing was this
and I was shooting the movie and then
every hour that I had outside of the
actual shooting of the movie I was
working with a karate master to learn
the karate stuff and you know and I was
learning the routines of what I had to
do I was getting very good at that and I
was proud of that it's all I could do
but I was learning the routines Lou was
also doing learning karate as he wasn't
this but he was for some reason he
wasn't able to get the routines it just
wasn't happening when we came to shoot
the scene I was so filled with the
routines and I had it down and
everything we started shooting the scene
he was struggling with it and I was
getting pissed off and we didn't have
much time to shoot it and but and I laid
off and I kicked him once I hit him
really hard in the gut and he said ok
that's it I'm out of here and he left
and which rightly so I had no right
doing that to him and he left and he was
serious he wasn't coming back and Taylor
and I looked at each other okay what do
we do now
and he made a phone call Terry got
Taylor got on the phone I said okay he
called some casting people said we we
needed six foot six black karate master
by tomorrow morning oh and we found this
guy in New Orleans and they flew him up
and we shot a lot of that sequence with
a double and it you know we did anytime
we had to do it very quickly but you
can't tell shot by shot you can't tell
so when did he come back to set two days
later again
any explanation just that was it it was
my fault I mean I take full credit for
having messed up right but was that a
dynamic that happened a lot I mean I
think of the scene where you're doing
the push ups and you know you're in the
mud and it was was there any kind of
posturing going on no I mean I'm I'm
believe me I'm a trained actor he's a
trained actor we were helping each other
we could we came up with the rhythms of
that ourselves of how to play that a lot
of that was improvised a lot of it so no
we were very much on the same wavelength
yeah the one thing I was thinking of
just logistically speaking when you're
doing a scene where your character is
doing push-ups maybe you can do hundreds
of push-ups I don't know if many people
can but how do you kind of save yourself
just physically if you're doing take
first time we were in great shape by the
way so the first time 80 pushups no
problem take 270 to go take 340 and and
then it was gone you can't do any more
so we started 98 99 100 and those are
the takes actually were used 98 99 100